une production du studio sf
mais est venu sans filtre le podcast on
parle de ce qu'ont vécu nos invités
dallas a scandé avec moins d'hommes
plantes et le studio sfr offre trois
studios distincts avec une ambiance
distingue pour l'occasion que vous ayez
un podcast web simulant un audiobook 1-1
entrevue à tourner on offre le service
de la techno nickel vient avec le
matériel la production la
post-production 48 ans après votre
enregistrement vous avez tous dans votre
boîte courriel service clé en main pour
plus d'information studio sr point ca se
nomme cette semaine cette semaine on
reçoit de nous inviter chouchou de nos
amis amis de podcasts ultérieure
charlton quatrième fois qu'on harcèle la
reçoit et on le toujours des nouvelles
choses à dire
on a parlé de sa nouvelle série
eva board qui est sûre vrai si moi je
les vois chez complètement c'est rempli
de suspense rempli de mystère c'est
vraiment une série de tucson dans les
règles de l'art on adorait ce aussi
parlé à ne pas l'être au niveau
semblable chef qui est aussi un ami de
podcasts qui vaut aussi comment qui sont
rencontrés sont raccordés grâce à nous
sans fil certains pourraient dire qu'on
est les espèces de cupidon du podcast
d'autres diraient pas ça mais à qui
jugent et
puis on a parlé de tout ce qui est aussi
les crimes et disparitions la
fascination qu'ont nos pour le to cry
pourquoi c'est aussi populaire en ce
moment c'est vraiment la chose
la plus populaire en terme de série de
podcasts sans ce moment et victorieux
c'est vraiment la reine queen du podcast
autant au québec qu'en france regrette
pas c'est nous les vikings
taquiner son tailleur
si jamais dans les prochaines semaines
je disparais durant le podcast vous
allez comprendre pourquoi
merci le podcast de cette semaine et
présenté par roxio qui est une compagnie
de services internet qui vient checker
le statu quo du monde la télé comme ma
soeur s'est abonnée à ox yopi un modique
depuis qu'elle a fait son changement
c'est le jour et la nuit avec le service
sa clientèle vous avez tous déjà passé
des heures et des heures at on à vouloir
parler de leur père changer votre
système avec option vous voulez changer
de forfait ou changer de forfait vous
leur écrivez-vous un problème de
connexion pour leur écrivait il vous
répond son gentil c'est rapide c'est
facile qui ont des prix des prix
compétitifs grand barbu types de prix
stables you peau frais cachés il n'y a
pas de facture qui modulent d'un mois à
l'autre des promotions plus tout d'un
coup ça finit plus on paie deux fois
plus près on se rend compte que pour la
même affaire ton ami paye plus où tu es
moins c'est un prime savent exactement
votre argent sans vos ou quand vous
abonner c'est complète transparence
totale une compagnie de télécoms honnête
qui sera un fléau si comme tu le sais
tout mais j'insiste là dessus le passé
chez les grosses compagnies y aurait
rien de plus frustrant seul chez oxz
tous arrivent pour lyon à cahors bat
internet ont tous ces obsédés par votre
internet que vous alors on a un code
promo pour vous pour un mois gratuit
donc vous essayez le service action si
vous n'avez pas ça n'arrivera pas mais
si vous n'aimez pas ça vous retournez
dans vos vêtements neufs c'est le code
sans filtre en un mot fait de tensions
demain
le podcast de cette semaine et présenté
par auch lag qui le fournisseur officiel
de tout produit alcoolisées et non
alcoolisées du studio sf qui lance
maintenant une nouvelle collection de
ceinture limonade pour recolorer ton
était à lyon quatre saveurs la grenade
mur rhubarbe et à nana on an'a pas avec
nous présentement parce que ils ont
tellement eu un succès qu ils n'ont pas
pu nous en envoyer on attend encore les
caisses mais d'hommes de hull de la
chance vous décor sculpté déployée aux
endroits aller plus haut la société
cherche là que j'ai c'est universel ce
qui ce qui nous est que ça à quel point
j'adore la scène ce soir j'en parle tout
le temps je passe encore et puis l'été
passé ç'a vraiment été au mont highlight
j'ai passé l'été à siroter mais c'est
sûr c'est léger c'est fun c'est bon et
ça soit les malades sont encore
meilleurs ah ouais pauvres et ouais la
bouche trou à mon but à moi sont
vraiment rafraîchissant sont vraiment
bonnes
ça goûte pas trop l'alcool s'écoute
léger
sait-on vraiment vraiment bonne 110
calories par cannette be 1 grammes de
sucre par canette ça va être un été
encore une fois en diable en diable xl
sur easy pieces merci la gagne deux
claques de colorer nos traités puis de
commanditer en fait le studio sfr on
continue comme ça on vous adore puis on
portman vote soit souvent oui si c'est
plus rare aujourd'hui que le mettent
souvent j'adore cela me touche dans les
limonades belle isle save sur le
management disponible en épicerie un
dépanneur aller ou comme ça you merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
victoria alors ça va mais toi jusqu'à
retomber
jamais venu dans ce local si non non non
mais non mais je vous voie sexuelle
avait sa chance
et plus joyeux que notre attention si
dieu oui c'est mieux plus lumineux ouais
mais vous fermez les rideaux avant moi
c'est ça
qui tu nous écoutes pis dans le cube
unique de fait avec bob tway géant et
oui la découverte a eu tant qu'ex
sorbonne en écoutant ce
que tu connais ce bob à vins qu'on leur
soit je sais c'est pas bob les chefs ne
s'était pas un coquet pauvres et moi
j'avais seulement pas de parler de lui
et moi j'écoutais tout vos épisodes déjà
fait car
mes
pilotes et l'équipe bob les chefs bon je
connais pas mais je peux noter c'est
intéressant que j'entendais parler
vivent les usa qui voit j'écoute tout
audio le hockey j'entends les pharisiens
sa lancée il est intéressant de tallil
google y glisse t il vraiment boosté
gueule puis je les range sur instagram
était juste pour
[Rires]
bâtir ya tellement de monde qu'il suffit
il à double passe maintenant au petit
peu écrit n'ont pas fait la stratégie de
décembre vraiment plusieurs images plus
beau point click est à peu près certain
ce poteau d'un spectre air la personne
aussi je n'ai pas ce mois
non la remarque a fixé ce fait comme je
l'avais trouvé superbe aussi par deux
rôles intéressants je trouvais y avait
des soucis bientôt y est je vous parlais
d'être ici avec les anciens modèles
achetés le truc pour ses toiles dorées
marquer mais il s'est fait couper quelle
machine à quoi s'assurer qu'ils
remarquent pas chez les autres - il dit
holtaas
cantona est sensible aux les sourcils
bonnes phrases souvent des soucis mais
moi moi
je dors blog existe depuis dans ma vie
maintenant le il existe depuis packing
longtemps c'est le premier livre de
recettes que ma mère m'a amené selma htc
l'anarchie culinaire selon bob le
chiffre jarrier pas je me rappelais pas
vraiment le souvenir de moi mettons
fin à de l'essence aux adultes qui
connaît pas bob le chef là c'est vrai
mais tout le monde qu'il ya beaucoup de
gars de ton âge qui ont acheté ou il y
aurait si les les
jeunes adultes cuisine pas non mais
c'était cool parce que c'était genre
comme voici un gars cool et branché qui
fait du skate puis qui fait un poulain
bière avec ses années chez le support du
httt cologne est plus que ricardo
[Rires]
josée di stasio
comme rien qui me rejoignait mais le
fait que je comprends d'être tombé
éperdument amoureuse et
même un oui c'est ça ça refoule bien et
puis c'est le fun de sortir sa
coupe mais quelqu'un qui fait la même
job que toile maintenant il va filmer
oui oui
fédérer s'est tous filmés puis
maintenant salon puis je fais mes
recherches je fais de montage petits ont
pu les contrarier notre combat qui se
sont comme tout le temps sans mais si
par le fait que commencer sur terre
aquitaine pluvieux web vous avez
considérable quelques références qui
sont poliment et beaucoup
beaucoup et moi j'aime vraiment ça c'est
aussi ça dépend de ce que tu aimes non
mais y ait vraiment un faux monsieur la
rencontre
oui mais y habitent quand on écoute
salut bonjour le matin
6h heure est venue
non mais c'est ça moi j'ai toujours été
attiré par lego un peu plus vieux
james beattie mais ça dépend ce que tu
aimes le il prêt paterna les ai quand
même c'est très protecteur vis moi
j'avais surtout
bref fait que ça fitte les deux je
pensais tout assorti lui avec des films
petit peu plus jeunes aussi parce qu'il
ya 80 coeurs d'enfants y vraiment
c'est en
plus on vieillit plus on réalise classé
comme c'est quelque chose qui existe oui
c'est ça existe déjà le sens terme
d'expérience qu'on
fait des jeunes vieux puits des vieux
jeunes oui c'est mon dieu oui
c'est vrai et puis
ça prend des coups tiger récemment les
ont fait un moment que marini
la compagne
de l'acteur est la chante clé d'ici ma
chanson préférée michel bronn d'esprit
du bob dylan
les personnages vrais fait qu à chaque
fois c'est le genre mais cette chanson
là c'était le chanteur
non
[Musique]
mais tu as quand même mais c'est quand
même un bon show qui le passé du mexique
à la tuque oui oui
mais tu as vu dans la dernière année et
demie au quand même changé drastiquement
leurs conneries je reconnais plus
tellement et la fille quand tu regardes
sur un ton loin des 10 mexique jardin
j'ai tellement changé le panic de
l'ouest cet avis
oui pied
pour venir à la séparation
faudrait sûrement juste d'un mais si
tous ces sujets et puis j'avais dit et
je pense que mon père n'a montré
ses seins je peux plus autres qui
avaient dit non mais le sait par mois
cette plaie de mont terri parce que
monter restée la ville où des tirs
étaient là tu peux tu es le genre fait
la différence dans tata est le thé on va
venir à montréal on est ensemble c'était
seul plan mais genre parce que j'aimais
tellement plus ma vie là-bas j'ai mes
[ __ ] et mes amis me taper scénarisation
mexique jamais pu ma maison j'ai bien pu
rien fait pour ce que j'ai essayé de
faire la différence dans ta tête puis
effectivement
non non on ne termine ça mais non c'est
comme deux personnes différentes puis
c'est tellement plus épanouie 6000
abonnés et me le disent certainement
mieux députée tsipi effectivement quand
même un gros mollets vivons dans notre
pays comme ceux complètement différent
un autre langue toutes les primes way we
say puisse pas moi j'en ai parlé souvent
lemay et j'étais comme immigrantes labo
belge en une entité unique en profiter
et puis il est au contraire plus le jeu
peut-être l'estragon c'est vraiment plus
une petite fille et le mexique blanc
souhaitait quitter
l'armée oui mais je le petit je vais pas
vécu d'exclusion est quoi ce soit mais
est tellement chose que j'aimais plus du
mexique le rappelle je critiquais tout
le temps pitt et il y aurait plus
d'ouverture et de booster j'avais une
rigole je me suis cassé ses jambes pour
critiquer c'est vrai les autres mais
j'étais juste pu bien et puis c'est
tough de se faire de nouveaux amis moi
je me rappelle mes meilleurs amis
c'était deux français estime un petit
jeu parlait la langue parfaitement
espagnol mais se fait deux amis
mexicains en leur disant
megaman et l'éloignement aussi tué la
famille liste à la fin les amis au
québec ça de manquer quand même ouais
non c'était pas ce qui te mangerai
venait deux fois par année pour rester
taux d'1 2 3 - fax respir j voyez
c'était plus mais à chaque fois je n'ai
ici aussi j'avais comme des événements
de job piégeant c'était comme ça casse
et voilà c'est ça aussi que je ne vivais
pas vraiment là non la vie normale si
moutons mais je viens pas une vie
normale là bas on sortait beaucoup plus
de vidéos je me rappelle je travaillais
beaucoup plus mais je faisais juste et
tout le monde me dit sur moi une vidéo
tout le monde me dit aux autres sans
moyens d'éviter au calme dans une ville
parce que j'ai une vie d'errance n'avait
pas du tout le tout à l'heure de toutes
les personnes n'étant qui créent du
contenu je sais pas pourquoi peut-être
que tu peux me l'expliquer tolar de la
personne avec les abonnés les plus
j'ai envie de dire un grand mais là je
veux pas faire une grosse généralisation
parce que sûr que c'est juste une minime
infériorité d'abonnés mais genre soit en
vidéo et dimanches ou telle vidéo et
comme à plata une heure et vingt et
comme 40 minutes s'est déjà au la
victoria tes vrais m'a vraiment plus que
tu étais l'avant et je m'attends
vraiment à voir une vidéo du noir et
blanc et les dimanches plus c'est juste
45 minutes
de
contenu gratuit grande qualité puis vous
qui allez parce que c'est pas la
durée habituelle n'a pas de bon sens
sultan pige en même temps at il dit
c'est tout le temps mais c'est comme un
ou deux commentaires par vidéo et
reviennent oui ce monde-là et écoute
mais aussi d'élus mais le genre de
gentils prendre la peine d'écrire un
email un peu comme en primaire à
quelqu'un pour 2 qui était déçu de moi
que j'étais plus la même fille de calais
se désabonner mon contenu était moins
intéressant qu est l audio tous bords du
genre j'arrête je réponds juste une
phrase le pour qui tu prend pour acquis
qu'on retient c'est que ça s'est passé
qui te leur dois quelque chose
du travail plus leur offre de contenus
aux autres consomment six comme s'ils
donnent à donna pigeon personne doit
rien à personne si seuls échanges
allaient faire des services est ce que
le coup d'arrêtés matin par peter c'est
aussi ton choix mais alors ok ouais et
qu'est ce que j'écoute religieusement
depuis plusieurs années il a maintenant
lequel jean nipon maquis sous écoute
journée on en a déjà parlé ou aux âmes
et on entend des coups de feu la bct les
séries télé
réalité5 et ouais ouais ouais je dise ça
va sortir de telle date ça sort pas
c'est pas si grave si j'ai une vie ça va
bien je t'aide tabarnak gens
souhaitaient se pose est aujourd'hui là
où tu es sous écoute maintenant il y
avait dimanche qui est pas sorti je
pense d'eux récemment le prix était
comme mon dieu jah man qu'on dirait j'en
sais mais je vois que jamais
ouais mais tu es en même temps c'est ça
moi j'ai une vie quand même charge et ça
ça ne fait pas un pli ça
met des gens que maintenant qu'ils ont
juste le henry dans leurs journaux me
regarder mal à ma vie des autres et je
comprends que ça fait leur horaire mais
non effectivement il y en a qu il faut
qu'ils contrôlent mais c'est vrai c'est
vrai que c'est toujours intéressant de
remettre en perspective
évidemment ça excuse paul le fit prendre
la dette on table permet de remettre en
perspective mettons les habitudes de vie
de certaines personnes puis certaines
personnes qui on en parle avec a dû
apprendre avec a dit justement de com
comment est ce que les mesures
sanitaires pileux l'aide de toutes les
restrictions avait plus d'impact sur des
gens qui à chaque dimanche sur groupe
est maintenant des minorités ethniques
les dimanches j'étais super important
pour eux puisque le il y en a plus de
parti dimanche c'est depuis que le site
avait travaillé toute la semaine dans
une job ne t'aime pas tant que ça pour
revenir chez vous peut y voir des amis
puis joe soccer les dimanches steppiques
et là ils sont plus là ça se peut que ça
d'un sapin influences plus que quelqu'un
qui la victime moi je dis évidemment que
pour quelqu'un qui travaille de chez eux
que des business qui peuvent continuer à
rouler ça pas beaucoup d'impact de sa
peau plus d'impact dans le confinement
plus à faire douter fectivement comme tu
dit quelqu un qu une vie active qui
comme elle des vidéos sur paul g
mais proportionnel aussi avec comment le
monde sont fan de toi le pij à l'ifan
charlton sont faits
chaque
mois ci mettons la série de star wars
guaino il sortait peu la date qui ont
reculé
mais mettons qu'on prend dans le fond
c'est qu'un
si petit que ça doit concevoir pour toi
qui as du monde qui sont fans à ce point
de toi c'est vrai qu'aucun produit
imaginé ça mais c'est
sûr que toi ça fait déjà un petit but
que tu travailles sur le cosplay
d'obi-wan kenobi l'adapter aux cas la
première fois l'accord
est habillé avec une robe
mais ouais non c'est ça c'est juste
parfait c'est le fun parce que ces mêmes
theillet mon corps nu mais des gens
publient des fois des commentaires
c'est intense et savez c'est surtout le
style récemment j'ai fait une vidéo puis
on me dis je est un autre débat
vidéo
les six jours avant mais moi ma vidéo ça
fait trois semaines
c'est long faire une vidéo bien
longtemps pour y envoyer photos qui est
très demandé la permission à tell you to
pas aussi kissed a girl
mais une quantité limitée de sujets
aussi le homard
à l'infini ouais mais j'imagine
toujours
connu ça faisait longtemps que blanc par
l'itc souk aient beaucoup d'informations
sur ce ouais effectivement est ce que
parce que là ça fait combien de temps ça
fait que tu te fais ta shine on you tube
le lait puis genre 2016 est ce que donne
fatigue ou non bonne question quand même
je travaille quand même vraiment forte y
mettons des photos montrent peu après
que tu fais pour te suffisent à part en
écoutant des vidéos s'est pas fait sur
le coin d'une table
spatiaux vite lassé du contenu dense de
qualité de la recherche pile d'une
scénarisation bits et l'on vidéo
est une fatigue de ça surtout avec le
évidemment on entend le rupteur mais
toutes les autres projets qui s'en vient
de chicken tu commençais à trouver quel
chaîne youtube des fois ça prend
mais oui puis non voter je vois que ça
stagne ou 6000 abonnés mais le bloc et
ça fait longtemps à 170 56 ans et 660
multi quand même bon ça montre le doux
quand ça monte toujours mais si à mon
but comme en flèche sur 20000 par
semaine comment va la vaste et genre en
faire maintenant je me dis une quantité
limitée de gens qui vont probablement au
québec deuxièmement en france qui vont
aimer mon accent social imiter son nom
mais c'est bon pour mon temps 1 millions
au québec faut que huawei fouquet
puisque la hyène madiba
madiba puis un accent
donc et
ça ça change rien mais
c'est bien période londres il ya des
périodes puis je le vois puis emmenée
par seth en parlais tantôt mais je me
sens moins passionné puis c'est comme un
sujet après l'autre toutes chaque
semaine sur un nouveau sujet qui en a
des sujets qu'il maquillait désabonnent
tout le monde me demande d'en parler je
fais une vidéo là tu mets ça me
passionne peu puis c'est vrai que la
passion de casser sa part eux dont un où
du moins c'est
ce qui c'est gégé travailler justement
sur la série télé qu'on en parlera plus
tard ça a été le choc et là j'ai ma
passion et du bac qui est des sujets que
je peux faire sur ma chaîne youtube le
cherokee à sa maman qu'elle est de faire
une bonne vidéo de même c'est que j'aime
vraiment le sujet ouais c'est juste
comme des fous mais c'est pareil avec
vous pour casser des invités qui vont
comme vous relancez
j'aime ce que je fais déjà racheté poste
au poteau
ses gammes à nice adding la pression de
la régularité de sortir tout le temps
quelque chose juste un maxi tu le fais
poubelles les gens leur marque quand ils
disent ça peut devenir âme ni par une
lourdeur à ce wiki est énorme et youtube
laisser l'enfant témoin cet été je me
suis pris 1,3 hausse mais peut-être un
mois même s' a publié sept à avoir en
fait je faisais ça de ma vie je n'ai
jamais vécu des choses et
que j'apprécie s'arrêter car
premièrement j'ai reçu plein de messages
deuxièmement ça a été quand même long de
recommencer à voir des bulles
vidéo j'ai ressorti après le jeta mais
on dirait que genre personnes la voix ma
vidéo en full tu le genre commence à
harponner le bide avant d'arrêter ces
foules de gens recommencent à peine
depuis on est au mois d'avril
ah oui vraiment habitée ou si d'autres
tous bardés tout comme sont arrivés
c'est normal c'est la nouveauté - ch
c'est de faire des trucs nouveaux le jeu
se rendent avec un monteur métier il
faut spécifier que mais le trou quand
même c'est gtc la fois la plus amère que
je veux pas regretter c'est ce que
j'aime c'est aussi loin
la notoriété en tant que personne
taylor audrix à des postes youtube le
vraiment noté maintenant c'est comme tu
es rendu un peu de la référence à tout
ce qui est disparition tout comme ceux
des piquets et qu'il ait su j'étais
saoul je te vois un peu partout pas
juste dans mon youtube le tout c'est que
j'ai l'impression que je le vis très mal
cayton la marque se jouerait les world
girls c'est comme de plus en plus
dépassés c'est un médium lund oui mais
ça reste que ce qui me paye sociétaux à
100% mais les autres des à-côtés le pied
puis autre ce ces machines c'est mon
candidat c'est grâce à mes abonnés que
chant doux je suis fait que je vais
jamais arrêté à moins que man est
justement sa peine plus du tout pigé
aucune vue le jeu tales même changer de
concept mais c'est pour l'instant je
continue jusqu'à
puis c'est aussi ça j'avoue que revenu
constant c'est quand même quelque chose
qui est là les enfants conçus par les je
venais de sortir
le tome 1 où il tombe de jeu par le tome
2 qui s'est garé depuis sa sortie romain
oui puis un roman j'imagine que on
étudiants sans
wayne j'imagine qu'ils ramassent quelque
chose que tu caressait depuis un petit
bout les romans de fiction dans le fond
puis qu'est-ce qui est comment est-ce
que le le projet né ça c'est vraiment de
faire un roman seul sinon comme j'avais
jamais fait si j'avais eu des cours de
création mais c'est pas pareil entre
décrire le asile tout ça écrit donc
l'idée est venue c'est alexandre
oubliable je pense qu'on avait parlé à
l'époque il m'avait crime à rapprocher
avec ce projet le lui avais pensé faire
il n'y avait pas de faire un film avec
ça c'était comme un scénario de film en
anglais ce que ce qu'avait écrit bien
sûr l'histoire était quand même
différent celui de tuer anglophone il
parle anglais super bien ouais et
visiter jusqu'à taba mieux se vendre un
scénario qu'il est bon la pandémie est
arrivé plus tard qu'ils vont ainsi pas
le moment de faire un film auquel 10,1
j'aimerais sud m romain en français puis
j'ai pensé à moi pour le personnage
principal est discrètement et spirit
ouah je pourrais écrire pour faire le
personnage principal le chanteur ben oui
et ça me genre je capote elle qui me
crachent préface juste après on me
parlait me dis est vrai en l'écrivant
semble carrément puis c'est de là qu'est
le projet unis puis le mot j'apporte
échalas apporter ma touche à l'histoire
qui ont été cités comme un squelette
histoire plus aux bénéficiaires c'était
quoi le processus d'écrire à deux
puisque moi me semble sur la forme la
plus contre intuitive qui j'ai pu le
penser le dessus ce lit mais je pense
qu'il est habitué à tout l'écriture à
quatre mains
c'est lui maintenant il ya des partis et
des chapitres qui écrivait c'est selon
comme le
mois quand j'écris c'est ce que je fais
et je fais un squelette de ce que je
retiens piègera jeudi leur travail
pendant dix semaines mais maintenant lui
c'est ce que faisait comme le squelette
ok ceci selon l'histoire selon ce qu'ont
établi ensemble histoire si on veut tel
ou tel indice qui va mener à ce que veut
mener le espace sur un chapitre qui fait
qu écrivait comme le squelette dis moi
j'allais rajouter et me l'envoyer plus
rajouter mais truc surtout les dialogues
je pense que c'est ma force lui sa force
et lui comment il décrit les seins et
une scène une description des lieux de
super bon là dedans ni super moment là
dedans donc c'est ce qu'on faisait et
puis d'autres chapitres témoin qu'il
écrivait puis j'ai envoyé à lui plaira
juste effet concentré changer comme ça
c'était pas ça c'est quand même bien
fait mais qui est ce que tu peux voir
maintenant de ton est à toi quand tu le
lis le roman est ce que tu vois des
changements dans la tonalité non dans
mon pays mais ben moi je vois pas on
est fans sont vraiment proches le fameux
non ça c'est quand même différent mais
je t'ai vu que justement il ya une
industrie ce qui passait par dessus je
pense que ça le comme tu unifier le tout
dans un peu le mastering ouais ouais je
pense que mais c'est vraiment si loin et
tuent dans les dialogues peut-être que
tu es moi je voulais que personne au
personnage mais y écrivait tout le monde
veut s'impliquer il parle que même dans
la ville où ainsi se battre pour voir
reconnaître des expressions à moi ou
c'est tout ou des bêtes mike mckenzie le
personnage principal est vraiment basée
comme sur moi le tissu
blonde de 28 ans qui habite à montréal
tu es bon ok c'est sur un mot ressemble
beaucoup à moi sans beaucoup plein de
choses que j'arbitre mobile lui
billetech au monde où jalabert et on va
faire davantage dans les montagnes puis
apporte d'époque des bottes vegans la
pop shop du tout
moi avec ce ouais ouais fn est strict de
l'escapade à la tuque les baby gunners
ces cuisiniers
mais voilà c'est ça ça me ressemble
beaucoup plus âgés comme aider pour le
personnel et personnage est ce que vous
êtes allés avec un français universelle
où vous êtes j'imagine que oui le jeu
m'avait de celui-ci afin will pour tous
qui c'est toujours ça dans mes livres
aussi le pied en plus mon éditeur et les
français donc c'est pas trop pire mais
c'est que le père de mackenzie mackenzie
le personnage il français sa mère est
américaine qui elle habite à montréal
fait tilt dans les dialogues elle a le
cul en mettant l accent sur le papier on
ne gère des gros mots québécois le
vraiment québécois y en a peut s'offrir
une tuque justement une tuque en france
et disposant d un bonnet ou un bonnet
ouais c'est mais c'est bien mieux que
roussey pas des fois qu'il était un sens
pas ce béton bon moment nageant en
france m'avait dit les les quatre flash
non dits des flots intermittents oui
mais nous en tout cas on va le mettre
fischer la veille 10 des oies des
warnings
je peux changer pourrait bref
ça passerait pas
par moi c'est vrai
on prend une pause dans le podcast pour
remercier encore une fois nos amis chez
oxz you optio qui est la meilleure
compagnie de télécoms vous avez fini de
vous faire chier honnêtement chier avec
des appels interminables avec des prix
qui change avec tout ça vous avez
terminé puis on y ont même un changement
de side vous abonner si vous allez
bientôt pour décider si vous aimez ce ou
n'ont fait que si jamais pour quelconque
raison tard ivre poule et pour quelles
raisons vous regrettez votre choix ben
vous êtes remboursé toutes les frais
tout ce que devaient débourser aucun
risque pour vous abonner axiaux vous est
remboursé vous retourner avec dans une
compagnie mais vous allez pas le goût de
retourner parce que les hawks hausse est
simple c'est facile c'est efficace le
service est bon
fac et pas de souci d'utiliser le code
promo sans filtre pour le premier mois
gratuit de hawx you fait que mercy la
gamme chez oxz you puis merci a vous d
encourager optio d'encourager pas de
casse par le biais d'options et de votre
présence en ce moment bref merci oui
c'est comme quand même puis là on a
parlé de thé de fait la tournée des
salons du livre avec ce il ya eu quand
une bonne réception le jeu c'est
peut-être un petit peu moins que les
premiers prêts pour ce point je ne sais
pas juste le fait que ça soit un roman
oui peut-être aussi les gens m'écoutent
pour des histoires vraies
sauf que le succès quand même puis le
est ce que en écrivant vous aviez en
tête un tome 2 ou non oui ça se termine
les enquêtes on n'en veut plus
le tome 2 mais si je pense qu'il faut
attendre de voir les ventes finales moi
je suis entraîné comme on tombe 3d
garder l'oeil ouvert fait que je peux
faire les deux ouais ouais c'est parce
que ses livres et spirent est aussi le
seul essai vampire ouais mais si tu dois
avoir le ton aura peut-être insein mais
cette manne projet du genre c'est comme
juste et et vidéo prennent combien de
temps tu as soon as ton mail ça m'a
tellement avoir un monta sur six mois je
peux l'aider rush le ch couple
hollywoodien
qui j'envoie tout se plier mais les
images pied les effets pays au monde où
ça m'enlève mais notons les recherches
c'est comme une journée pour une vidéo
de 20 minutes c'est une journée entière
filmer le des roches une autre journée
d'axpo super league et jusqu'au moment
du papillon mais des vidéos du nord jean
fête ses 40 ans c'est l'enfer j'espère
cette vidéo du nord c'est comme écrire
un livre un jour là ni documentaire
c'est une scène beaucoup plus des
cépages arles s'est passé par deux la
consommation rapide youtube le net comme
métaphore c'est ça qui paye le plus nous
sommes fait capoter légende médias après
tellement voir tel film documentaire
sont netflix telle série sur sur l'
affaire dont je vais parler mayhem
soutiens mes vidéos de 1h et plus
sinon c'est fou la casse id de recherche
que tu flippes que tu as fait le tir à
travers tout le temps oui le coq de
checker le
[Musique]
n'ya pas grand monde parents qui ont
plus
un coffret limité de gens qui est plus
au courant de ce monde lequel à
l'identique par an en france méritent
pas la francophonie en france pensent y
participent aux français auxquels
l'armée cours de littérature de la
francophonie on avait peur on utilisait
pas la france oui
mais oui utilisent eux aussi bien auprès
des français comme ce fut le cas en plus
d'abonnés que moi puis way coût d'accès
mais oui tu as tu es plus ils sont
écoutés en afrique sont écoutés
et en belgique était plein bay en
afrique parle français
mais beaucoup c'est
pipi comme vous êtes en tout match
manquera jamais de sujets il ya tout le
temps des histoires écrites put que tu
peux trouver de l'information sur ces
histoires le au pied ben écoute s'il n'y
a pas d'information que jeter mais dont
le qui je pense à une sorte de dimension
que j'ai fait
et tu vas sortir dimanche et c'est une
femme les années 70 disparus j'aimerais
ça à boston ok mais ce jeu m'a pas
contacté la famille c'est une sorte
super connu il ya plein de formes
indique déjà qu'ils donnent leur série
pleine arctique et des documentaires
factice jeu capable a eu plus d
informations quelque chose sur internet
de faire une vidéo intéressante mais je
préfèrerais une vidéo sur la personne
qui a disparu l'an passé ici à montréal
mais le forgeron gendreau contact avec
la famille qui fait qu oui toujours des
sujets de tilly meurtres irrésolus en a
tout le talent des disparitions c'est
fou le malheureusement les cadets en
femme c'est donc un habitué sur twitter
je réalise que cole semaine plus de
disparition compense le oui parce que tu
attends pas
je sais que tu partages fait
je partage je
peux pas être au courant de tout mais
c'est l'arrêt des mutations est ce que
c'est ce que je me suis dit justement
peut-être que ça nous amènera à parler
de la série mais les troquets dont tu
parles la série ces trois noms que
j'avais jamais entendu une prime et
s'habiller non non bâti je suppose
activement les corps inanimés les autres
noms mais justement je te le dis c'est
ça c'est juste trop mais dans fois que
donne à voir tellement de gens qui
disparaissent comme ce dans des
conditions vraiment louche qu'on
n'entend jamais parler puis
tantôt dessus on commence à parler
justement avant commençait de la série
pile de la jeunesse de tous tu ne parles
et comment que ça commence là ce serait
bien plus joli total c'est comme le
projet le plus excitant matériel pied de
az qu'il ya des bouts de combat pas
danser ça me fait autres mais comment ça
commence et baisse avec mon urbania qui
m'ont approché non fonds pour faire une
série de croquis puis en ce moment c'est
comme la faire tout les diffuseurs
toutes les maisons de nivelles du tout
quand même s'il fut le danger pendant
que je faisais avec urban ya déjà trois
autres
présomption approché pour d'autres
projets mais je fais pas parce que
j'étais déjà qu'est ce que l'on
reviendra jamais à cette question à sa
glace on y reviendra temps à tour mais
qu'est ce que ça nous dit de celle de la
société on est tombé
excessif et quand ils m'ont approché il
n'y avait pas autant d'idées ont juste
dit on veut faire de quoi avec toi plus
j'ai dit ok bon gars on préfère moi
c'est des disparitions qui passionne
entre guillemets août ce qui m'intéresse
fait qu'on pourrait
chercher les personnes disparues
carrément fait qu on se dit ça a été un
travail un projet de deux ans le j'ai
rencontré le réalisateur s'est parlé on
ne travaille ensemble puis ça nous a
mené à ces personnes le conflit chercher
imagine deuxième plus longue liste plus
un fait acquis bedat co le sait c'est
que le plus de douze mille dix toiles
plus intéressante on voulait faire six
cas au début quand on a réalisé que je
pense qu' aux débuts des bleus on allait
faire des vidéos de bd les épisodes
d'une heure que finalement ça le vide
comme été réduit et bombes les fassis
comme la presse juste avec ses 3 que
l'on n'avait en masse il ya même des
choses qu'on ne peut plus m mais il y
avait d'autres qui nous intéressait
aussi je pense que si une saison 2 l'on
croise les doigts on voulait mettre
saison de plus à ce passe comme vraiment
campagne officielle s'est louiseville
yamachiche saint marc sur richelieu
pileux je pense qu'une saison 2 - autre
que moi ça serait mon souhaite faire ça
en ville genre à montréal les
disparitions du trafic humain vraiment
ce que je voulais faire je dois fait qu
moyen orient ah oui
ferrer paul gardet beaucoup des grosses
villes toronto montréal
calgary qui en a beaucoup et ça
ça me donne froid dans le dos de ce
trafic humain j'ai vu une vidéo
dernièrement c'était genre une vidéo
caméras de surveillance puis c'est quand
même j'imagine que c'est en amérique
latine mais je suis pas persuadé
puis à qom et un char qui arrive puis le
cas où la porte une petite fille qui se
promène avec son sac d'école ge vient
pour passer plusieurs groupes permettant
de deux d'abord display ils marchent
packing vite vers la petite fille
clairement dans le but de la laponie de
la rentrée dans le charge puis une
madame qui voient ça arrivait genre qui
une jarre deux jeunes femmes comme début
de vingtaine qui voit la scène qui
parlera course qui fait juste poignet la
petite rue du jard la tasse et
pleugriffet jusqu'à arriver à côté de
chaque rentrée dans le shop sonore mais
quand tu vois ce genre mais tu dis ceci
la caméra le panier une fois où est-ce
qu'une madame que vu la scène qui a
intérêt interview tv revenue très mais
sinon la petite fille qui revenait
peut-être l'école est disparu à tout
jamais à nancy devient esclave sexuel
qui exporte dans un principe des
milliards de dollars
ces gens rassure la petite fille à
rentrer chez eux est ce que j'ai vu que
l'on va dans une vidéo de deux ans là tu
le mets une an et demi mais grâce au
trafic humain à montréal ça se passe
parce que sous nos yeux mais beaucoup
des agences d'escortés mettons qu'un
souvent cassés s'ils avaient caillassé
des russes des ukrainiennes ça arrive
souvent qu'ils ont été amenés si
puissants qu'ils veulent pas être là
pour le futur ou des salons de massage
ouais maintenant oui car c'est écrit
maintenant belle russe et je lui ruse
qui vous font des massages des bars de
danseuses sa
phase pour épicer alors que le gros du
trafic humain le 2 ça se passe attendez
genre cinq pays matin en russie
alors que dans l'orne europe de l'est
roumanie on est beaucoup
plus les envois fait ils envoient ben
justement en amérique du nord en
amérique mais aussi en amérique du nord
bref fixé trafic humain c'est aussi de
la prostitution juvénile de force il y
en a ou de la prostitution de force noté
côté petit pays des salaires ridicules
l'opt et été retenus fort sill drogue
pour
protéger et on va pas nécessairement
mais
je pense l'année passée le lieu à laval
qui avait qui avait fait venir une jeune
africaine il y avait payé la famille l'a
fait en dix ans avec un montant qui
était comme considérable pour eux parce
que c'est une famille qui vit dans le
tiers monde il a payé puisqu'il y avait
un échange je prends votre fille la
petite fille c'était quelque chose comme
6 ans qui avait passé dans son sous-sol
a comme se faire agresser à tous les
jours puis même des fois et ses amis qui
venaient peu
comme retrouver le genre on est amené
quelques éleveurs flag un gars laval
l'année passée c'est fou comment
comprendre le monde comme ce genre
qu'est-ce qui commet qu'un humain peut
devenir aussi ge a perverti le genre ces
grandes jusque le peut-être capable de
piatti y en a qui ont carrément les
double vie qu'on leur demande dans leur
sous sol ils vont travailler puis 11
affaire sion de la normale plus jamais
tu aurais pu penser que ces mégères à
quel point il est déconnecté mais quel
point il est quelque chose qui cloche
pour que comme ce cas pas de faire
suffit de
[Musique]
visiter les gens faux pas qui a créé
pour claf la personne crie pas par là
qu'il faut qu'elle aille
paris match fou
mais pas tous des enfants aussi et des
filles pour mon âge quand je serai plus
vieux mais
l'état c'est qu'ils sont pas niés
là-dedans 25 puis montréal c'est
qu'apparemment que c'est comme quand une
ville pour le tourisme sexuel qui comme
l'a reconnu mondialement je pense dans
le top 5 des vélos mais parce que le
monde vienne pour camille surtout par la
fin de semaine là du grand prix c'est
comme un geste à faire fouet ce qui
viennent ici pour comme des perversion
ultime balle est dans le monde
sait ça mais j'avais vu j'en lis le
pistaient avec justement quand bangkok
puis jordi villes de même taille comme
mauriac était d'abord au centre de cette
liste le
fait qu est ce que tu penses que ça dit
de notre tour de la société soit
tellement mis de l'avant puisque
maintenant une série sur deux sur
netflix sur prime sera la russie c'est
une histoire de chiu prime le jour 2 de
ce même pas exagérer non puis on les
regarde [ __ ] exhale de gym je laisse
les voies mais je vois tu le
sais pas je pense qu'on s'est toujours
intéressé à ce
cm s'était pas autant que ces outils on
a vu ce canal d pour écouter des
initialement mais là il y en a sûrement
qui ont parti la mode jean despas de gaz
moi je pense que c'est pas aussi dès
qu'on le croit si je pense que c'est
juste en ce moment tout le monde dans
les côtes et on a toujours aimé se tait
on aime ce sila kiosque juste les modes
pendant cinq ans après des shows de
cuisine jean oui oui
mais je pense que c'est ça je pense pas
que ça va rester c'est quand même métier
c'est triste pour moi mais maintenant je
pense qu'en ce moment on aime ce parce
qu'il y en a beaucoup c'est accessible
qui on écoute subissez un
genre de montagnes russes des sensations
fortes de l'adrénaline que ça procure
d'avoir peur puis le monde sait
peut-être année mais moi c'était surtout
seul au départ c'était comme kelly film
d'horreur me font plus peur à qui je me
retournais vers des histoires vraies
c'est vrai que ça glace plus le samedi
histoire vraie que béton voici ce
qu'elle est c'est fait décent réussi des
films d'horreur mais je pense qu'il ya
plein article là dessus pourquoi les
gens aiment le trottoir mais je pense
que c'est pas si dépenser jusqu'à on
aime ça parce que c'est une curiosité
morbide justement puis
puis on a toujours aimé c'est y pas
pensé à toutes les émissions aux études
des klein aux états unis toit ni toi ni
en sorte misterrecycle existe depuis les
années 80 en renfort n'ont tellement les
chemins mais si nous sommes si proches
suite dans sa salle existe depuis
toujours c'est juste que l'oeil ans de
plus c'est vrai qu'à canal d je me
rappelle le dos si longtemps je me
souvienne y avait des jarres de des
genres d'histoires vraies de trucs rails
mais comme
un genre
réacteurs
pichichi processus et km le tout est
rentré dans la maison
[Rires]
avec la montée des tss est ce que creed
qu'on use to crème qui mettons fin des
séries pas des podcasts et eu plus
facile ou plus difficile qu'avant mais
ton point de vue
avoir accès à l'information ont parlé
aux familles tout ce
je ne sais pas
avant c'est facile parce qu'avant c'est
plus le fun mashaie comme la première
personne d'autre avec le monde capote
elle c'est quoi ça oh mon dieu je savais
pas que ça existait vers youtube heure
de trop quand même puis le monde capoter
là dessus plus et comme rendu
normalement jusqu'à une parmi tant
d'autres mais aujourd'hui il y en a
beaucoup pour avoir accès à
l'information
c'est sûr qu'il ya des disparitions
mettons que je vais google une
disparition je pense pas qu'elle connut
moi sur mon dos network mon site là
dedans
nous bénévoles fait que je tombe sur une
disparition que je lis un peu la
personne avait disparu d'une manière
assez oui j'ose google et son non plus
je vois crise jean reinhart et décrit là
dessus il ya plein de son
sobre et des de consacrer 7 personnes
choquées évidemment c'est ce que le
monde est invité c'est vrai oui
effectivement c'est plus facile d'avoir
accès à l'information mais les fumées
dont les familles déco célèbre lundi
avec la montée justement de tout le
contenu que tu croyais mais ils doivent
se faire à shalit report de bon sens
maintenant et
je pense à mort américain le cole
disparition le plus célèbre aux
etats-unis s'est rendu au lieu de
tourisme parce qu'elle allait foncer
dans l'honneur en charge via les départs
et après puis le disque bowl à miami
comme une grosse boucle jean ruban bleu
tout autour il ya des maisons pitt et
chaque maison chaque propriétaire de
maison et tu un peu impliqué dans
l'histoire où on passe près distincts
suspect ou si une personne ne peut
logement telle personne à quai à l'hôtel
causé crunelle telle personne à le
parler à la fille de brefs mais là et on
la ville ont dit la ville c est vrai je
pense new hampshire et on dit on veut
plus personne dans notre ville en lien
avec moi mais là on n'est plus capable
maciel à mon niveau justement pour eux
pour fouiner du dr izzie fait
qu'effectivement les familles mais sa
dépense helikos pas célèbres comme je
pense à john boehner a visité la petite
miss lot qui s'est fait assassiner sa
famille doivent être plus capable
imagine tu veux juste qu'on passe à
autre chose pigiste avis même pas
l'aider et s'estiment de
bottes de radis thormann kinship vous
pour que de poser des questions le qui
était déjà répondent à lille fouet puis
marchethon terrain qui check trafford
des plans pour que pour ce qui est il me
semble ne jamais entrer en contact avec
eux mais genre pour des cas justement
que sont pas connues les familles sont
vraiment reconnaissante le pij j'ai
de l'intérêt sa plume à valence et à des
enquêtes ou abîmés jusqu'aux antilles
qui sache pas parce qu'ils doivent voir
justement tous les documentaires sur
toutes les personnes disparues puis 10
voyons moi mon fils ait disparu pourquoi
personne n'en parle il est moins
intéressant que les autres c'est ce que
je me dis je sais pas c'est ce qu'ils
pensent mais juste de savoir qui on
s'intéresse on est encore le pion
nouveau on est plusieurs à essayer de
trouver ce qui est arrivé je pense que
ça tout alors peut-être que non mais je
pense que la plupart des familles sont
utiles des familles tu penses qu'ils
soumettront qui sont approchés par
netflix pour georges thoma parler du
corps mais que
penses tu qu'ils peuvent capitaliser là
dessus en ce sens que tu as quand même
une industrie mettons qui génère des
sous parce qu'il veillait de rami qui
disent que je parlais mais genre pour un
montant x ne laisse rien le mais pas
pour moi mais pour une fondation ou
beaumetz toutes les femmes les familles
ont toujours besoin d'argent les
recherches pour payer un détective privé
pourrait faire des affiches pour des
débits chutent il n'est pas de quoi y
ont toujours besoin d'argent fait
qu'effectivement moi je demanderais
montée ont toutes dit guo fin 2010
devant les portes pour tout le may en
plus plupart des familles ont dit qu au
fond de mes pieds
4 je faisais les
victoria sioule dans la creuse
c'est surtout battu les faisait
y en avait un suspect que je me suis
neutre on met à l'avant où est ce que tu
avais traiter d'un sujet puis qui est
finalement ça l'avait aidé à la
résolution ou de pistes de solutions
allant kathy cook et en plus la fille
marie elle que j'avais été qui
d'ailleurs alain pas de cassel sur elles
et réparties sur un compte
réel quand justement dans la série a
mené on va au bout du tuyau pour
l'instant c'est vrai oui mais oui c'est
marié fkl melandri qui espère on dirait
qu'elle est adoptée car ils en parlent
plus et pas résolu mais ça c'est comme
l'inca qui me vient en tête que j -p
j'ai même temps aider le sujet ce qui
d'ailleurs est écoeuré que tu en parles
de comparer ces marie-eve amélie 101 me
dis alors derrière moi mon père il a été
assassiné il ya vingt ans je sais c'est
possible c'est qui qui l'a assassiné
après je me souhaitant pas sur ta chaîne
ou plus j'étais j'ai eu un flash que ça
faisait longtemps je vais faire comme
ces entrevues avec des gens impliqués
dans le jeu quand des victimes mais je
disposerai tutoie venez raconter
l'histoire de ton la mort de ton père au
studio t on on se donnait rendez vous
bien de tout raconter il suit au podcast
à la diffusion du podcast et à lui comme
un outil ça pas été si facile je dors et
ayant notre tête qui était pas content
d'entrer dans des histoires de
disparition de meurtre une moitié la
famille je veux pas parler
indivisible si c'est quand même que tout
chez les lourds des fois mais bref elle
est dérangeante de cluses ne pas avoir
soutenu mais j'ai une petite ferme
honneur de vivre de la scène qu'il faut
tourner la page puis on continue avec
d'autres nontron sa course il vraiment
oui on le voit en ce que j'ai vu dans ma
série mais
c'est à ça j'ai été contacté par des
gens qui ont dit nous on sait que tu es
tu on parle de si peu c'est un sacré
petit je pense qu'ils étaient quand même
impliqué dans le monde la drogue qu'elle
a appris plein de choses sur son père
justement est par la suite elle s'est
fait raconter plein d'histoires casse
avait peu puis à donner des noms qu'elle
a donnée à 10 ans 14
puis je suis en cas edge ces petits
s'ils se passaient plus grand chose dans
le dossier de son éloquence
allait débloquer oui mais je sais pas
s'il va les arrêter mais je me rappelle
c'est marié va donner des entrevues moi
aussi j'en parlais un peu le manet
markets asia dit le mans il y avait
arrêté sa part celle en route à la passe
et non une enquête a fait rouer bref je
sais pas comment ça s'est passé mais tu
es je pense poli j'ai j'ai fait quoi ce
soit c'est juste j'ai donné la plate
forme justement quelqu'un pour qui en
parle jusqu'au 26 appuyé le ca s'est
rendu deux oreilles de personnes qui
avaient peut-être d un faux
nom était au courant depuis résolu
maintenant oui ok après vingt-six bon je
veux parler en voyant t sa fille grandit
plus vient une belle fille était belle
jeune dame l'asie qui cherche son parti
comme entrepôts touché par ce qui
est en dehors des trucs comme ceux qui
sont arrivés sur des vidéos datées à des
entrevues ou
sais plus ce que j'observe c'est par
exemple des familles en france beaucoup
qui contacte ensuite à ma vidéo ben ils
vont une affaire 0 connu sur google le
nom de la victime y est particulier rien
moi je veux en parler et par la suite le
quai je veux dire à mes abonnés à vous
allez vous abonner leur page facebook
puis genre à la page facebook la
desproges bons et
il ya une page vos familles si vous
voulez aller donner bon pilote il est
quand même genre de phénomène qui se
passe et le par la suite la fille mère
ou les proches il faut inviter sur des
plateaux de télé et des articles sont
écrits sur la faire par la suite parce
que les voix conclut jean reno me fixer
plus je donne la visibilité genre que
les médias traditionnels vont donner une
plus grande visibilité à ce mets moi je
pensais plus ce que je fais pour aider
vraiment le pas ce qu'on me demande
toujours te tirer ce lieu
parce que j'imagine que dans toute cette
culture là de tchouk rhymes c'est
mettons qu'on pense tu peux aller au
plus creux d'un sobre et 10 depuis
peut-être trouver des infos mais
j'imagine qu'il doit avoir une certaine
culture aussi dans le dark web ou est ce
qu'il doive des infos la banque export
des affaires que qu'on n'est pas gad de
trouver sur google tu mets ton ou sur
reddit sur des sites accessibles de même
j'imagine ce
thème un peu et d'un coin bleu en plus
de mes seins métriques foule je voulais
elle manie déjà je mettais tout informer
commenté quelques oies télécharger pour
avoir accès finalement je les prophètes
mais et
je sais je sais pas trop si moi je pense
là c'est le seul moyen que je verrai le
que prédit le mais je connais pas tu en
sais mais ça serait déjà pu
je veux jamais faire sur l'homme était
il ya des méthodes pour les vieilles
peut travailler pour les vip regarder
carrément des pays pour te taper des
vidéos de l'humeur khl ben oui ou genre
de la deûle à noailles pu identifier un
garde chasse était le petit fils qu'on
trouve pullulent depuis dix mois au képi
l'heure on voit le gris portant un
masque mais le il ya des objets dans la
pièce les vieilles se demande souvent
l'aide du public justement d'aider à
identifier des personnes des objets
genre qu'est une paire de shorts le
gecko léopard motif savez-vous d'où sa
vie lorsque ça vient de tels pays requis
égouttement
c'est ma ville je me suis il n'avait une
quête a été invité à tout moment par
l'autre comme une enquêtrice puis elles
pâtissent à jobst et sunu faste à
pelleter toutes les vidéos pressé de
trouver les coupables ip de film super
méchant jobs
sapera tout courage
arrête être la personne qui tranche la
gorge des cochons à répétition
su rentrer chez vous le soir puis comme
se lave les mains puis s'en va pour le
foot
c'est un brin déjanté geof essentiel
qu'est ce que oui on enquête là-dessus
qu'on était de trouver les formes ya là
dans sa ferme mais genre cette femme le
qui rentrent chez eux qui
m dos il a offert d'y ranger ce mais
c'est impossible
françois 6e puis pas passer à succès des
images qui te poney venant pitt ses
mains que vous même ce méthode peut
activement maintenant que la personne la
plus rationnelle au monde entier peut
activement fermer ce dossier leur tête
remettons le ton subconscient sans
rappel puis la nuit de 46 par avait des
fois cris
non mais il y en ait vraiment des bons
psychologue je pense pini psychiatre qui
les suivent le je peux me croire mais
le dark web
10 95% des pages de couette c'est juste
que des scans pour essayer de voler tu
étais pas car
c'est gentil mais ton favori boutique
mais tant que tu veux engager un tueur à
gages mais vraiment tout pour être à
gages mais c'est juste pour piétons
qu'ils
sachent comment se déplacent mais
il y avait un youtube heures que je suis
qui faisait seul georges visite le
dacquois tête avec lui plié sur sa
caméra tout à sa page piste intéressante
mais mon frère de contacter un oui on
s'est parlé
le sujet du prochain film est un peu une
histoire
baiia ne parle
pas de tout repos
le film était une histoire critique
ebang justement dans l'encré dans le dos
d'un procès dans le temps qu est ce qui
signifie que tu avais écris parce que
justement comme on dit tantôt t
mais c'est bien pour lui le scénario
c'est quand même vraiment très
intéressant petit lui fait foi les
recherches commencent comme thomas c'est
quoi les applications s'apprend qu'est
ce qu'on trouve là dessus tpiy
évidemment c'est comme si c'est fait
pour ça soit comme un thriller mais
c'est quand même c'est effrayant pareil
si six autres courses qu'elle a dansé
vraiment des choses puis probablement
que ce sont des choses qu'on lui trouve
là dessus c'est comme mes s'étoffa
trouve et il faut que tu saches ou a les
bras trouvait justement lien apparent
souveraineté libre et blum le titre
phare de la torture en ligne s'il y en
eu le matin apparemment un petit peu
payé quelqu'un pour garder je veux tu si
copenhague
je pense que oui mais ceci est
accessible ça doit être vraiment of a
trouvé je pense pas que ça c'est comme
le feeling si on peut l'imaginer ça
existe
mais c'est sauvé tant de vies parce que
je te menti à la police il ya du monde
qui fait leur job s'y trouve et ce
serait fou que ça
m'évite de sud mais
on parlait de chamant d'information puis
de quoi est-ce que depuis la série il
des nouvelles informations qui sont
rentrés sur ses collègues qui dit les
choses qui pourraient amener à comme
faire avancer ces dossiers là
ça fait juste ce jour
mais je veux vraiment rien dire le may
you go salle 11 mai du livre tu me dis
et et moi je pense jadis et qui que tu
es francis albert ces brefs mais dans ce
genre où je connais quelqu'un qui disait
qu'il a lui-même fait que les chiens
comme ok tu veux tu nous en son nom in
touch et le salon via valises à la
[Musique]
casse étaient pré écrit moi j'en écris
moi pas c'est aussi ça arrive souvent le
doute est pas la crédibilité de gamme
est assez source le fait que écrit moi
de manière anonyme puis d'autres
monnaies non parce que nous on peut
aller fouiller l'hôtel nous on peut on
peut aller chercher à cet endroit là le
fait qu'ils aient d'autres monnaies non
peut-être saison d'autres on viendrait
l'action est ce parce qu'on en avait
comme une liste de noms si on avait reçu
des noms de moi c'est cette fable parce
que faire une série comme ça ça doit
être un méchant casse-tête légal pareil
parce que tout à fait repris fait
classer comme qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
qu'est ce qu'on peut produire j'imagine
que plein de choses plus d'informations
vous avez eu vous avez pas le droit
mais il ya plein de moments qui
échangent à regarder la série et le papa
on appelle ici on n'a pas eu le même ça
j'avoue que
c'est mon réalisateur sait pourquoi on
est passé et d'y créer ce genre c'est
l'art que c'est légal en toi mais c'est
sur une scène je peux se rappelle je me
fais comme henry je parle aux suspects
leur droit dans la sphère sur le poids
pris par 1000 ce qui je l'appelle au
téléphone avec puis on en fait c'est pas
mal on appelait on enregistrait au genre
jallet sur les sur plage avait un micro
caché ben t'as passé je pense à lui
entendu toit et ont dû couper ses
répondra lui avait un micro caché des
fois des places ah ouais plusieurs fois
mais a fait mais après tout c'est leur
demande si ça s'était comporté ton image
ou ta voix fouquet accepte mais oui pis
lui et y
j'ai même pas dans paris mais t il moi
je ça me fait par le team également
menacé puis et
m'a pas mal ces mordus quoi ce soit mais
juste menacé de poursuites pin
et
j'ai passé ce matin et si c'est lui que
je pense le
suis aussi c'est lui que je pense je me
dis que j'avais par le dit des fois des
moments pas rester chez moi tout seul
puis une fois que tu désires rentrer
chez nous genre durant l'été du genre et
on sort le soir
sur une rue par son kayak s'est trompé
ou je sais pas mais j'ai déjà appelé je
ne fais que pleurer choses parce que je
finis
j'ai vraiment eu papier et je me dis si
tu lui dis que je pense pas que ça soit
lui mais je me disais tu penses tu
penses quand même quand sa gestion des
questions j'ai posé parce que c'est dans
toutes les personnes à qui tu parles
mais beaucoup qu'ils soient vus le poète
à cameron doivent être anonymes qui ont
bâti leur voiture pile apporter 10 parce
qu'ils ont peur
mais toi tu fais à visage découvert
c'est comme tu va gratter le bobo on va
parler au monde des fois avant que je
suis propre
nom et b
tête manquée qui ont envie que lorsque
la séance s'est payé mon équipe de thé
je t'aime mon réalisateur aux rivages
amené met en danger je fais toute
confiance et et urbania
mais c'est vrai que des fois je suis
dangereux le chairman et on est allé sur
une propriété privée mais moi je t'ai
hardy games afin au début j'avais porté
par les juges avaient demandé dans un
salon qui si un employé telles hausses
de juste fallait se fasse mais j'avais
comme un micro caché du film et des bas
ceux ci étaient stressés les sériephiles
en plus dont tellement stressée pour ce
qu'à la fin il y avait comme une
propriété privée qui était clairement
appartenait un cube de mentor à dix
jours des barbelés au niveau même genre
sur quelques coups en dérision il va
obliger à la danse
mais on est tous ces pilotes sa boucle
on le peut
or il ya plein de votre
métier mais mettons c'était suspect le
seimat ont ils voulaient pas parler avec
âme héros il est hideux du genre tu as
envoyé promener mais en même temps
admettons que donc ce pot lui le way
mais ces publics tout seul avant tout ce
qu'on dit rien de bon ok mon passage ici
on le voit large en entrevue il doit
être méditée mais maintenant qu'on parle
pas de lui mais qu'on parle d'eux en
général c'est d'être soupçonné quelque
chose puisque poteau qui le fait puis
mettons le seuil sous sillonnera cas qui
est fait sopi leurs bons qu'ils ont dit
qu il mêlait à chaque fois qu'il ya une
nouvelle enquête ont à nouveau
touba qu'un parti comme tout le temps et
qui
doit maintenant l'accumulation de
manitou on
se dit aussi dans un tournage c'est ce
qu'on est intense le tuer mais moi
c'était moi qui demandait un non plus
ajouté devant des tirs intenses mais en
même temps dans l'histoire il y avait
comme deux pour me semble même temps
comme deux qui sont vraiment louche le
petit dans ma tête et je sais pas tu es
moi c'est ce que je dis ou de même je
lui dis dance et hip j'en revenais pas
cher c'est bon j'allais déjà les dix ans
et yes j'étais content parce que j'ai
dit une personne disparue il ya cinq
personnes dans le bord qui sont présents
dans le barème dont 5 4 5
avant cas de passage en quelques minutes
avant que disparaisse ils ont tout
accepté de me parler sauf ici une
personne qui accepte de parler qu'est ce
que ça dit sur cette personne ce qu'elle
ait quelque chose à cacher pourquoi elle
ne veut pas aider une famille en
détresse une cache une personne fait
juste me paraît juste j'ai appelé jeudi
au téléphone je viens en paix je veux
juste posé quelques questions système
pas je l'accusé pas de rien mais là sa
réaction celle qui s'est le sien lui ai
pas parlé
c'est une seule vie entre bref on dit
quoi d'autre à faire mais c'est sa
petite boîte un meurtrier je ferai
d'abord de l'air du gars qui veut y
collaborent
le problème étant que leurs tripes décès
de collaborer puis pour être capable
pour être capable d'avoir collaboré
droit de mentir et puis pour mentir
les chances que tu te fasses paniers sur
mensonge sont garants c'est juste
d'accepter par les mettons deux ans je
vous parlais jour avoir mis à jour super
cas
super 15 joueurs super course super
coopératif t'arrive le permis ne te dit
quelque chose plus la personne pékin
c'est parce que tu vas me dire le sait
c'est juste faux genre mais on s'en est
rendu compte dans la série il ya comme
deux et témoignages un gars qui dit
aimer ton moi je te lis je partirai
taylor puis
est resté seul à boire mills mais jean
ribul abord mais qui dit mais non il
était logique afin et puis je
dis une affaire de même que quelqu'un
peut facilement contredire déjà été fait
mais non c'était mieux dire
personne
je pense là mais moi moi je ferai comme
si j'étais une super effectivement je
ferai
comme ça je pourrais pas te dois rien
je dis que c'est parce que tu veux pas
retourner le temps mais c'est vrai que
ça de la ruche
c'est soit un verre d'eau chaude est
garanti que des coupables mais si ça
mais encore une fois je vais faire
l'avocat du diable ainsi mettons
généralement
[Musique]
mais émile seul on est con on a observé
toutes les possibilités c'est sûr
qu'elle était victime d'un meurtre ont
choisi c'est sur la 95 % d'accidents de
retrouver son corps est pour partie et
pour partie un peu décidé de faire sa
vie ailleurs une sortie comment sous le
mode d'un bord et et moi était quand
même si loin 3h02 3 heures du matin sur
téléphonie arrêté de fonctionner à 3
heures du matin son genre ne jamais
retrouver
puis ce
fake empire
il y avait
une ou deux personnes dans le bar avec
elle à ce moment dans le bar mais dès
qu'ils te parler à nous parler plus sa
coupe que avec sa coupe syfact rocade ou
13 n'ont aucun d'eux n'est pas
parce que je c'était moi qui connais des
dix points qui
vous pouviez pas mettre mais vous avez
juste garder le factoring et n'ont aucun
nom et à mon dieu je prête tellement
dans la sphère londres et que je lui
parle en ce moment
comme alors
on va le résoudre
et zou
est-ce que vous avez le droit de même de
dire mettons nous on pense que non
c'était maintenant je pense pas non mais
je pense qu à aucun moment je la dis non
non non je sais ça non
ce serait peut-être que je les dis mais
ils ont peut-être coupe est aussi le
meilleur non non tu peux non non non
c'est son nom est
n'ont jamais d'avis et ça s'est
tellement touch et le niveau légal puis
il ya une personne qui a un plumitif a
noté laurent en cours on est sorti un
plumitif c'est quoi ça c'est comme un
registre de des accusations ou quand on
est arrêté ou je pense et ce quand est
chargée ou tard été
mangés a pris bernard
challandes elle lui seul avec une
avocate qu'est ce que ça nous dit de de
telles personnes dans la série c'était
super intéressant puis ça mais on voyait
je pense qu'on aurait enlevé le nom du
que mais même pas je pense pas bref on
ne peut plus laisser se demande si on ne
peut plus non même temps s'ils
comprenaient je comprends moins c'est ça
dans les dents et que disparition je
viens juste de penser à ça parce que le
cas mentionné au passage comme si
c'était un moyen d'une main sa forme
mais le j'imagine ça arrive c'est juste
du monde qui décident
de ghost et leur ville ces deux gestes
forts genre ciao bye je le dis aux
joueurs de bruce wayne en fin de fin du
dernier batman webcam n'est fait de
disparaître genre bosnie s'est plié
comme jusqu'à corps en italie
avec un nouveau nom et une nouvelle vie
maintenant que mais comme le doute
l'éditeur qui remonte pas s'exclame
michel
la tête balayons la grâce à
son métier mais le sahara était
confirmée à truyes retrouver vraiment
son cas inquiète ouais sauf que l'équipe
ans qui aurait fait qu'ils
s'ajustent pour barnes et puis comme ça
n'allait
plus tout à fait que sa mort oui mais
jusqu'à 10 par
an et demi
si m il disait que la plupart ces gens
l'aise on les appelle des scripts parce
qu'ils s'occupent de terre-neuve gagne
beaucoup c'est m'attendait je te dresser
peut-être 1 70% m non non le sma
statique américaine je sais pour
gorilles mais c'est qu'une majorité des
disparitions que ce se voyant n'est pas
moi et je pense pas mais premièrement tu
le vois c'est que ces dix enlèvement
parental parents tous bords du lez le
parent et son enfant qui sont portées
disparues sont inquiètes par le mais
pense pas que ça se soit terminée en
drame le choix d'attaquer par mais son
parti disparu vers des boues qui sont
dès que je vois dans les disparitions
mettant quand je fais le doubs networks
a dit one day by day police si sur
quelques y est il va chercher ses
poussées fait qu'il y en a beaucoup tom
hanks et pour ce n'était que tu décides
juste de refaire ta vie sans raison
c'est plus rare et
mais il donne à voir le tir mais tient
maintenant moi je me dis le mettons
met donc demain matin je me
focalise maintenant je sais pas
mais tend de 7 passes et le scénario le
plus
c'est facile mais moi je me dis je me
dirais maintenant
premièrement pipi comme pilote le monde
activement de recherche le team et on
claque la police puis que le
gouvernement implique le fils puis tout
le monde te recherche maintenant mais tu
disparais laurentides mis à l'essai
comme brin moqueur tu prends un avion
vrai remettons rester
au canada elle aussi
peut conduire le côté avant que
l'image des mets ton tu es dans un
village dans les montagnes au pérou des
plus anonymes que c'est ce cas aucun
doute parce qu'après ça ici ma tante est
obligé de petite taille fine c'est ça
faut que tu fous que tu es ya peu de
temps par carte je voudrais qu'il n'y
ait pas d'attendre affiche pour tout le
monde il y a personne que des affiches
la plupart montpezat fiche de 10-6
maintenant je sais mais je me dirais
maintenant je répète genre au vietnam
travailler dans une rizière puis genre
payés avec l'argent c'est juste brûle t
car tu prends un avion jusqu'à en europe
du brut les cartes en europe le footsie
ce fait le trajet jusqu'à
trois ou
quatre ans avec du cash moutons tiens tu
sors de mes pièces plus le têtard et
atterrit à paris
qui pilotera sa préface avant que les
gens seraient se rendre compte de ta
distinction ouais c'est
exact mais tient avant que le monde mais
tombe lem un flag que je suis partie de
sa doctrine une semaine oui pis pour
aller au mexique est à présent ne pense
pas mais les
gens se parlent à voix haute et rendent
en amérique latine des paiements
d'option
je pense que
c'était parce qu'on parle souvent mais
comme tout les codes qu'on se crée dans
société puis comme quand on se bâtit une
jarre des jarres de prison de voir ni
même le type tu dis finalement c'est que
le sont à risque de briser à ta propre
volonté mais je pense aux témoins en
prison la réserve exemple mettait pas en
prison ela de ses deux enfants avant j
-c ben ouais par les joyeusetés heureux
ouais faut vraiment pas que ce soit un
vrai chercheur non quelqu'un avec qui tu
cherches tu as ta famille te cherches
monte à 1000 watts à quelqu'un amène le
village au vietnam fréquentes chez
google
c'est arrivé alors
viens pas dit si tu le
fais
je constate que
j'attaque ça soit de la barbe à fait
capable
j'imagine que beaucoup d'échos
disparition qui est finalement on se
rend compte que c'est parce qu'on dirait
que dans des affaires de même là
l'hypothèse
du meurtre et comme c'est la dernière
option c'est souvent la dernière option
mais des fois c'est peut-être la plus
excitante quand on veut plus croire sauf
que finalement l'accident ou thé
j'écoute étant tout à vidéo
obstacles oui pis que tu parles d'un
coup tu es vraiment célèbre salaam c'est
ce qui a l'air de fuir quelque chose
mais finalement c'est comme la chose la
plus probable ce qui est ainsi qu aux
pics et c'est la fille que tu ne devrais
pas le
dos à un
accident même que qu'est ce que l'on a
réussi à prouver que mais premièrement
on n'avait pas le rapport d'autopsié
avant le fait on sait qu elle prenait
pas ses médicaments pour la bipolarité
bien prenez juste s'il n'existerait pas
si dexter mais ces antidépresseurs ou si
j'ai un autre mot pour se le cache en
bref après les passes et stabilisateur
d'émotion d'après n'est autre chose qui
le poussait dans une manie le mans magny
fait que ça sera fait qui rentre dans
l'ascenseur
j'avais des hallucinations probablement
mon ses pommes est ici est en psychose
arrêtait les hallucinations puis je
pense que et peut-être monter sur le
toit le regarder dans le truc de est
peut-être tombé c'est comme cela voici
ce que je me cachais là-dedans twice as
et sa voix ça j'avais 17 ans je me
cachais
bref fx on a pu voir sur le rapport
d'autopsié est avec nous et je pense
qu'avec lui dans ses poumons ou une
affaire de même si tu le vois le package
sacré pu sortir de là
le truc c'est qu'elle n'avait pas ses
vêtements étaient nus ont leurs tenues
que ses vêtements à côté dans l'eau
métier en même temps tu as peut-être en
crise d'hypothermie christian
l'événement le fait que mais oui c'est
moi j'ai tout le temps et moi je suis de
plus en plus plus en plus vers ce genre
de héros des rationnaires j'imagine que
l'explication la plus simple la plus
probable c'est souvent le plus souvent
ce qui sape en scène ont annoncé sopi
bas on s'épaule c'est une casse et des
disparitions même aussi j'avais je pense
j'en avais déjà parlé ici où je sais pas
mais mettons et puis ya plus d'hommes
qui disparaissent que des femmes le
c'est comme si foule on le voit beaucoup
narni mais moi je le vois aller parce
que le challenge créé des profils de
personnes savent exhale vous aviez
beaucoup d'hommes qui disparaissent mais
la plupart du temps c'est du suicide moi
je sais pas encore dans les statistiques
parce que c'est ça illumine une bonne
partie de tennis potez des maires de
tetris le 6 mai il y en ait beaucoup du
sud si tu veux pas que l'on trouve ton
corps c'est faisable le toit de ses deux
valises à mes parents ont peut-être pour
éviter à leurs familles des coûts moins
ce que les traumatismes de tomber sur un
proche
oui mais tu es mais de plessé de l'être
devant les
enlever la vie
le traumatisme de pas pouvoir
faire mieux aussi sur l'autre la pire
chose si c'était denis pouvoir dire que
le jeu c'est pour un fait que les
personnages morts où je suis pour un fou
qu'est ce qui s'est passé
dans le néant ça doit être là je pense
que tu peux jamais connu de l'image
jeune dans une rizière au vietnam le
chemin
des gones à la série 10 de son ami dit
qu'il disait tout le temps moi je vais
aller son pelage qu'ils imaginent ce une
plage puis c'est beau c'est vraiment
à l'écouté la série
c'est un art on me dit christian ses
charmes et ses vrais fous tu ta bonne
havre et être payé le kentia ce pigeon
mais le programme a tous été projetés
d'abonnés 3,20 le ton le juste abonnés
pour un mois et en assiégeant trois mots
gratuite avec helix bref mais aussi tu
sais quand tu penses à cela ok ça te
coûte combien le cinéma jean 15 pièces
si minime se regarde un film mais là ils
sont vrais être plein de séries clips du
contenu québécois ses condisciples de
quimper 15 pièces pour avoir un mois
contenu je trouve pas ça si priori mais
non mais j'avais vu le porte parole
ça commence que je me dis que je dois
payer qu'inspire affecter la série mais
j'ai finalement 15 chats pays pour
monter une série qui n'en écoute et
plein d'autres apprécient ça mais on
n'est qu'au lancement est grand parce
que tu mets ton toutes ces plateformes
sur google qu'on paye 15 pièces d'or 15
cas ça s'accumule c'est que moi même
temps il finit de contenu et chats de
littéralement et de contenu c'est une
scène ça fait beaucoup
d'abord désabonnent vous êtes abonné à
tout
mais tu sais comme 15 kg à ce genre
aucun problème à aller dans un bar puis
trois cocktails et 15 bien
prendre un cocktail
qui n'empruntent plus qu'un mais d'en
faire de même c'est fois c'est comme non
non je me suis fait un commentaire de
ckoi gélard l accord de la classe
moyenne en plus donner mon argent
quebecor faut que le ch est vrai je
pensais que j'allais me refuser une
oeuvre genre de faire une série télé
parce que conscience et roshan c'est
quand même le space pas ma faute mais
qu'est ce que j'avais je comptais le
payer ses 7 passes tu as refusé parce
que faute de main et oui les moyens que
ça trier toute une série qui a fait
tourner pendant longtemps du monde des
recherchistes et ça prend des moyens
farine c'est
normal ça ça peut donner des noms
pourquoi c'est pourquoi c'est pas
gratuit
gratuit sa chaîne youtube gratuit
mise à part de plus
plus haut niveau mais tombe
effectivement quelque chose dont je
pensais à ça parce que les bleus 30
secondes dit que plus de disparition
d'hommes que de femmes nous on attend le
plus soin par les disparitions de femmes
on dirait principal du white
comme quelque chose dans la femme
blanche qui part et qui est comme ça pas
très content qu'il soit on n'en parle
plus que n'importe quel autre type de
personne qui dit oui on peut le voir
laïcité est l'exemple parfait c'est
cédrika provencher
merci à toutes les autres disparitions
là puisqu'on dit mais c'est moi nous
emmènerons messi parce que ça colle à la
pause pas juste parce que c'est une
femme c'est souvent l'âge de la victime
si elle est belle ou pas sa classe
sociale et tout s'est vraiment influencé
comme la manière qu'on va traiter sa
satisfaction sur meurthe le lavaux que
les médias vont en parler mais des
exemples de maladies remettons petites
filles noires d'un quartiers plus
défavorisés aux états unis qui disparaît
une journée le lendemain cette fée
blonde aux yeux bleus qui disparaît le
lendemain tous les médias en parlent et
la petite fée blonde puis genre lotfi
avant deux trois articles apple c'est
incroyable ils disent c'est flagrant le
phénomène loin et exige tout mon média
j'espère qu'on va parler de diversion de
femmes autochtones et où tu te fais où
il peut j'aimerais c'est peut-être pour
la saison 2 mais est aussi les sommes
qu'on parle peu
mais aussi les affirmations de m on
parle on parle pas de station d'adultes
tant que sur tant que ça puis même mais
il semble hélas le plus le même
traitement médiatique que cédrika
provencher si je peux en vivre
c'est juste deux choses complètement
différentes fait que j'en parle depuis
j'essaie aussi sur ma chaîne de de
varier un peu le poste juste parce que
je suis juste mes vidéos que je plonge
en parle souvent sur des femmes blanches
le qui disparaissent des belles filles
l' université qui disparaissent a pas eu
tellement mais tandis qu'une dispersion
de regoûter ordinaire et c'est que
patrick est impliqué dans drogue ce
sapin beaucoup moins bon mais pourquoi
est-ce que cédrika provencher s'est
d'ailleurs été médiatisés comme ce même
passé c'est une belle fille beaucoup sa
mécanique c'est en direct c'est être des
mesures et le moment parce que tu es
maintenant je me rappelle
de resto jarnac bo est ce qu'il ya comme
des affiches de disparition le à
l'entrée houcine apprendra-t-on je me
rappelle d'avoir un proche de la maison
des parents puis pendant ce temps là à
peu près pendant le temps où est ce que
c'est que peuvent en revanche et faisait
vraiment la une je me rappelle est allé
là puis avoir vu mais tandis plein de
visages d'enfants marqué genre
rechercher puis avoir pensé que ça
devait pas être vrai parce que j'en
entendais juste pour parler de ce jeu
m'a dit maintenant ces images là c'est
sûrement une affaire de com et net
appelle le piteux demande l'argent pour
x ou y rappelle m je me suis dit il doit
pas disparaître tant que sur pour que
cédrika provencher on entende parler
autant j'imagine que chaque fois que ça
arrive on en entend parler autant mais
c'est possible non c'est pas ça surtout
belle c'est de rester parce que par au
visage des enfants que des visites parce
que c'était en ce moment c'est pour
l'effectif peut plus agir quand
immédiate et sur le coup mais non ça je
pense que c'est ce petit a vu ses
parents la télé son grand père était
folle et qui était vraiment touchante if
i de trot rivière sens a été tout le
phénomène c'est un kidnapping aussi la
femme et la petite alicia les cdd à
chercher un petit chien
et une acura on savait le modèle je
pense a été tout seul le phénomène
s'était dit y en a eu avant la
dispartion puis le visage qu'on voit
souvent sur le temps les mêmes nous s'il
y en a tellement d'autres lots des
enfants ont disparu qu'on va pas leur
visage
gens sur des affiches à l'aréoport le
messie de creative le petit ariel il ya
quand même eu ils sont pas réels à
montréal lieu qu'à un réel coup à coup
et un petit gain près de la rivière des
prairies moi j'habite et d'insectes dans
le temps puis avec deux affiches partout
bon à lui en a beaucoup quand même c'est
ça heureusement lui ai eu comme une
bonne couverture médiatique mais
couverture médiatique
médiatisation parce que c'est un enfant
mais encore le
sait puisqu'il peut qu'on devrait pas
métiers des enfants sont encore plus en
défense mais effectivement et il ya de
quoi que tu peux le cédric à ces
ossements avaient été retrouvés un beau
test est même pas je pense qu'une partie
de sa mâchoire on n'a jamais retrouvé
comme le corps comme les causes
possibles mais cinglant ferait aussi
savoir si c'est avec les animaux mais on
n'a jamais suscité qui non plus mais ça
point de voir quelque chose quelqu'un
ouais mais on peut le dire le numéro un
si jeune adam était le sport je pense
passation et s'écrit pour moi de mai on
lui aussi têtu disait l'avocat du diable
on on dirait que lui et imaginent ce
pôle il est là bas ça si c'est moi c'est
ça sa vie doit quand même un bonbon à
lui perdu
deux points été
travaillé chez vous mais à sa compagne
il avec sa femme ils pillent ont changé
de nom s'accompagne ni même de la
famille parce que la compagnie bt je
pense qu'ils ont dû changer non
effectivement à cause de ça mais et avec
juste des petits signes aux lotos qui
avait je pense que la journée qui ont
retrouvé sérieusement il s'est pointé à
l'hôpital puis fais déjà parce qu'il
faisait une crise cardiaque mais faisait
comme une crise de panique loin mais en
même temps tu est accusé depuis le début
c'est le suspect numéro un ici il sait
que ça fait de la merde pour lui les
jours à venir dès les mois à venir - ou
si je ferais mais je pense que ça fait
longtemps mais je pense qu'ils
conduisaient la voiture qui était
recherché mais là faut nettoyer une
enfant d'un mois
c'est sa mère pamela sélectivement que
citoyen tabarnak parce que c'est parce
que six pour lui imagine sa vie est un
cauchemar si celui-ci est vite en
cauchemar mais au moins c'est pour
quelque chose qui a fait s'imagine spa
lui savait très sèche morts puis servi
de charvier paul
ces bons bénéfices dit mais
je me souviens qu'un qui comportait
beaucoup de la farce et recule depuis
avant qu'il ya un suspect
jeu suivent des fois tu es maudit en
mouche moi je pense et le père
a même été pire je ne la mets tellement
tabarnak c'est comme si c
il ya tellement d'options vous avez
tellement monde c'est juste qu'ils ont
dit que c'est comme le monde regarde si
comme c'est un film que tu écoutes un
film ça va être un des personnages dans
le film tu vois tu coupables afin que sa
voix de quelqu'un que tu vu piquer
directement au début le sait maintenant
il ya dix personnages
enfin si lui ce quartier qui doit
étudier ba ba des f-16 l'aja s'est
jamais la personne qui soupçonne le plus
jamais la personne qui te soupçonne le
moins fait c'est tout le temps la
personne qui est une liste de dimanche
mais comme siloti la fin de la partie
dire que puis le mettons acquis belle
angie j'ai le personnage la marge des
personnages par exemple ma part mais une
fonction des vitraux parce que c'est les
trois personnages du film
n'importe qui était heureusement et
malgré que les parents justement les
proches c'est maintenant je pense et
c'est cette taille des statistiques que
je prenne un peu maigre en tirez pas
mais et il m'est aussi des statues
observationnelles parce que je suis
tellement les dossiers tu peux avoir
mais c'est souvent épars ans on est
parent ou un père n'ont qu'une tante si
souvent seul bébé coûte kidnapping
quelqu'un te graver dans la rue en
europe pour le sait très attrayant nommé
il s'est vraiment rentrer
oui les parents sont souvent impliqués
mais mais le step osseuse était pas
souvent taux d'intérêt au parc acétate
enlevé système le père comment tu le
perds mon rapport la bonne façon de les
paul hippolyte ils ont sûrement
interrogé en premier défenseur lattaquié
mais lucie st quand même du bien sûr
j'aimerais
l'épreuve quand même incroyable mais la
folie vrai je sais pas si longtemps un
montant deux et c'est une même source un
petit 2 lui fugue il paraît
maintenant dans une petite ville en
angleterre puis prend le métro le train
jusqu'à à l'ombre qui on le voit lille
12 ans i sort de long du métro pont leur
voix puis jamais c'est comme s'il avait
planifié un peu son voyage chez avait
dit prix est juste un billet aller et il
y avait emmené son petit genre son game
boy je sais pas trop mais j'ose si c'est
une fille que c'est sur lot ici il fugue
et puis peut-être quelque chose qui est
arrivée par après mais le port est était
tellement soupçonné long terme elle pas
il travaillait au travail et au travail
et puis il ya des images de son physique
sword sur wii wii n'est pas tellement le
quai puis j'avais été en contact avec ce
monsieur l'oeil avait été parfait vie
m'avait dit ça tellement été dit s'il
m'a neigé genre son gym enlevé la vie
pour qu on al qu'on arrête de porter
l'attention sur moi puis qu'on pense
qu'on cherche mon fils pour de vrai
en plus de délits que le deuil de berton
fils foutu de l'ex ce
cas
il doit tellement avoir quelque chose
d'absurde et ont indiqué qu'un c'est pas
toi et me trompe ce quelqu'un c'est tous
cas pas maintenant quand quand c'est
quand il perd même temps que la police
arrive chez vous le tout je pense que
ils viennent demander mettons des pistes
de ce permis dans leurs questions tant
que des pets un suspect de l'histoire de
l'américaine si vous venez de me
demander mon camarade en état d'ivresse
et ce genre là qu'il offre je suis
officiellement un suspense histoire
alors que je pensais que vous veniez que
s il fallait tout ce que vous pouviez
pour trouver mon enfant terrible
qu'est ce qui arrive et qu'est-ce que ça
en vient baisse est en train d'écrire et
tombe droit de garder l'oeil ouvert et
je sais même pas si je les têtes manche
et même pas eu le droit de le dire mais
bon tout le monde à savoir le mets est
vraiment content d'être ici et mes deux
amis marche du projet avait pour secret
mais non pas tant les projets secret
juste peut-être du projet alain telliez
sur la sur la glace le con on continue
vous avez procédé en deux ans encore on
se croise les doigts on se croise les
doigts date la réception est bonne
petits moyens on se croise les doigts je
pense que parce que des bonnes chances
bah non je sais pas je peins bosse chez
tv au maire a dû avoir pas mal de monde
comme moi qui sont abonnés à avrillé
peut voir les premiers ce qui est ce que
c'est assez fou j'étais ok
ils m'ont les gens vont aller voir le
premier épisode puis sa bonne pub pige à
ce que tu devrais pas faire mais ils
vont le voir qu'il ya vraiment beaucoup
de villes sept mois ce premier épisode
le
tuffeau sont les séries qui ont tant de
temps possiblement c'est donc c'est sûr
vrai ouais c'est sauverait ou sur cube
sûr que c'est
httt les sentiers en livre audio touche
et on est en train d'enregistrer le
romain puis pour moi le une actrice
comédienne jouer les personnages ça va
être cool mais non c'est ça mais
redescend sinon
on le suit sur toutes les plateformes
actuellement
en europe prochainement oui à paris la
semaine prochaine on ne se l'est
parisien pourquoi 4 à la foire du livre
comme toi quand tu vas en france le le
monde se déplace le tec et roule
ou labour lancé en même temps le talent
y a pas longtemps je sais pas s'il va
voir autant de monde que les autres fois
mais on me reconnaît jamais dans
répulsion me reconnais comme un petit
peu plus mais pas trop non plus mais la
beaujoire jamais je suis ta baraque 6 à
paris et surtout plus tôt bob que montre
comme un feu de camp et celui ça n'a pas
de sens si agents des lunettes fumées
une casquette massif bob ça fait
longtemps qu'ils existent tout le monde
aime bonne nuit les jeunes aiment bob
les matins d'un beau petit nabot mais
c'est drôle parce que maintenant on va
vendre mars à filament voit reconnaître
bob la fibre noire
commerci